you you you have experience of vicious
animals you've worked creature I feel
like I've had a lot of professional
dealings with animals I did a film I did
a film with a lion once I just shoot
with a with a lion you know a wild lion
and what I say wild I mean he's been in
films we had to do her I arrived to
shoot this scene and I the first thing I
noticed with the camera crew were in a
steel cage only big enough to contain
the camera I thought I'd better ask some
basic safety questions I said what is
what this is the sort of safety thing
here with this wild lion and they said
well the first thing is we make sure
before the lion works we make sure that
he has sex just to take the edge off and
I said well though I'm not particularly
worried about that
I'm not worried about a Randy lion I'm
more worried about the eating kind and
they said that's all right because we
will feed the line we won't feed him too
much because then he'll go to sleep and
I said again that's not really does army
know what it's like you open a packet of
crisps do you have one but then you can
and the third thing they said the third
sort of safety measure was that the
Lions downhill and he's very lazy and he
probably won't chase you and again I was
just not really reassured by this and I
said to the chat but what you know what
if it does happen what what are you
supposed to do and he took great delight
that South African handler took great
delight in telling me that if a lion
charges you useful advice you have to
reach back you take a handful of [ __ ]
you throw it in the Lions face and I
obviously said where'd you get the ship
from and he said don't worry it'll be
there
[Applause]
[Music]
you